what's up
guys bang bang it is lunch money
time well wall street's trying to get
rich for us let's just try to get a
lunch money right i'm here with pelina
whatever that look is and she's got her
plant let's just get the plant out of
the way come on it's show and tell
time just get the plant let's go what's
up with this plant
this thing showed up in our apartment it
came really beat up that's why one side
is kind of dying
but hold on show them that look at the
tomatoes okay
this is ridiculous he hasn't decided if
he wants to live or die yet but i'm
trying to make it live
all right once more is now sponsored by
block five block five doesn't give a
[ __ ] about your plants
blackfy just wants you to go open an
account and get eight point six percent
apy
in an interest-bearing account they want
to get you money get paid go get a block
by account i'm an investor i sit on the
board i'm a user i'm happy you'll be
happy everyone will be happy if blockfi
has you join and get an account 8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account
you can buy and sell crypto you can take
out a us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you got a big purchase coming
up or something
go get a blackfy account so that i don't
have to listen
about the plant anymore all right what's
the plan have to do with your bitcoin
come on let's go okay
well we if we didn't buy the plan we
could have bought more bitcoin but
that's all another
okay billionaire hedge fund investor
uh is it henry stanley not henry stanley
drunken miller
oh oh wait no not drunken druckenmiller
says he owns bitcoin uh and he said that
he said his gold position is many many
more times larger than his bitcoin
allocation but he predicts that his
bitcoin allocation will outperform
are you guys paid attention yet this is
the best investor on wall street
period hands down really everyone
that you were the best investor on wall
street nah
i'm sitting on the outside yeah yeah
stanley drunken miller's compounded
money at over 30 percent
for like 30 years it's insane what he's
done
and now he owns bitcoin and he's talking
about it publicly on cnbc
if you're not paying attention now
you're willfully ignoring it
that's fine hopefully yeah you're just
not gonna
benefit when all the other smart
intelligent
billionaires smart intelligent investors
are watching as bitcoin disrupts gold
go ahead next
big news spotify is buying
podcast ad company megaphone for 235
million
marking its next big step into the
podcasting industry spotify is really
trying to beef up its podcasting arm
remember when i bought
um uh gimlet and what was the other one
with a p
anyway what it bought a few cast oh
podcast
is one of them and gimlet and now
megaphone
and also joe rogan and also kim
kardashian a bunch and also michelle
obama okay go on
daniel eck is on a mission he's gonna
own podcasting he will literally come
buy your microphone from you
if he could he's going to buy up as much
of this as he possibly can
he believes very deeply in podcasting
he is basically just putting all of his
attention and focus
uh there are rumors that they are going
to launch a
uh podcast only subscription so you
don't get music you just get podcasting
uh all kinds of things around exclusive
interviews content etc
kind of like the netflix for podcast
we'll see what happens
but spotify ain't playing around here
that's a really big bet they're making
on uh podcasts given that their music
arm
is so successful why are they doing this
well it's all the same it's just audio
right but the whole thing is podcasts
actually have better business for them
because they don't have to pay uh
royalties
oh yeah see
very different so podcasting uh is a
much much better position
uh for them to kind of dominate um and
so i i
assume that they're gonna continue to uh
to be pretty aggressive here
and uh you know it's one of those things
do you think there's gonna be more
podcasts or less podcasts in the future
it's definitely gonna be more so they're
uh moves
i literally still remember when cereal
came out i think in like
2016 or whatever it was or 15 and people
were like oh my god we're a peak podcast
there's so many podcasts
and then the the onslaught avalanche of
podcasting came and people were like
never mind there was not a peek
okay ready go ahead beyonce
uh sorry peloton announced tuesday a
multi-year partnership
with beyonce to produce exclusive
content with her music for its stream to
workout classes
because her music is the most requested
on peloton so they're going to create a
series of themed workout experiences
across multiple fitness categories
including indoor cycling running
strength
boot camp yoga and meditation is
the details available uh how much are
they painter
oh i i don't think it said it's crazy
because peloton only has 3.6 million
people
but still that's a lot of people members
well the churn is very low if you
remember you're more likely to
switch cell phone carriers than peloton
so that's why they keep growing but it's
still pretty uh it's pretty small
how much do you think she's getting paid
how much yeah
uh for something like this it's
definitely a couple million bucks you
think she got equity
uh well they're a public oh shoot they
are
public so peloton is public they may
have been able to give her some like
some kind of shares or something but uh
it's less likely than if it they were
yeah
sorry i forgot that peloton went public
guys
walmart said that it will kick off a
pilot with crews
that's general motors um driverless car
situation
to deliver groceries and it's testing it
didn't walmart get rid of their robots
or say that the robots in the aisle
was going to be a little bit tougher
than they thought yes so they're really
trying to figure out this automation and
robotics and stuff which by the way is
good like they're a huge company
and so they're embracing innovation like
i actually think they'll figure it out
because of the approach that they're
taking
but whether it's self-driving cars for
your groceries
uh or it's robots like that's cool they
just love a good robot
you know what else i think about this
story is it's gonna be very interesting
to see how many people
order groceries after the pandemic is
over
oh right because during the pandemic
there's like a
massive surge in online grocery or i
mean it's convenient and also you know
you can get toilet paper instead of
fighting the two
25 year olds were trying to court it
at the grocery store why are you
attacking 25 year olds i'm not
okay they attacked me um so
so here's here's what's interesting here
um what's interesting sorry i forgot my
thought i was gonna say something around
like how
uh the yesterday when the vaccine was
announced
all the stocks like zoom and like the
indoor stuff
um all the pandemic all the
all the stocks that benefited from the
pandemic
went down because people like oh wait we
might not sit inside all day for the
rest of our lives
uh i mean look it's short-term price
movements don't matter it's all
just emotional trading from uh from
investors
all right next oh this is my favorite
story
mcdonald's yesterday announced the
plant-based line called
mukplant which sparked confusion among
investors about whether beyond meat
would be a supplier for mcdonald's
mcplant the company made the meatless
burger patty for a mcdonald's test in
ontario but nobody's commenting
so people are like oh my god is beyond
stock should we invest
more in it or should we bet against it
if mcdonald's isn't using beyond meat
for these plantless
what people didn't realize happened
yesterday was
uh the stock the mcdonald's that made
the announcement
it dropped then all of a sudden they're
like wait wait but we're like we're
participating in this like we're helping
mcdonald's then the stock exploded again
but then the earnings came out
mcdonald's said they haven't made a
decision yet well that's might be
mcdonald's whole
position but that's not what beyond meat
said yesterday during the day then the
earnings came out last night how
what does the stock down go to the top
the stock is down no right
there 28 it dropped 28
they threw up a absolute goose egg
they just threw up a goose egg not
really a zero but like
not good stock they missed i think the
estimate was they were gonna do like 120
or 130 million dollars
in revenue they did like 90 or something
like something like
not even close uh which is not uh not
not good performance
go ahead well and then uh beyond meat is
like i will say this everything we said
is true now it's up to mcdonald's to
like you know
confirm it like i'll buy it for a second
all right elon musk says boring company
is setting up its operations in austin
texas
oh you like that austin texas yeah
yep so it's gonna it landed a deal to
construct and operate a people mover for
the las vegas convention center what the
hell's a people mover
um so yeah that's cool should we move to
austin
you asked me that every lunch money i'm
personally not opposed to it
there's a lot of lunch money viewers in
austin should we stay in new york
um should we go to montana no why not i
don't know
what about california no no i'm not a
fan what about miami
no i don't like the tank tops that the
men wear
all right so we have new york and austin
maybe puerto rico how do you feel about
charlotte north carolina
why not nah why not yeah all right
all right next we are at my favorite
segment
you see how my nose is on my nose
guys yesterday i was out and i came back
and he
like i apparently didn't notice he got a
haircut but doesn't look the same
like it looks the same how am i supposed
to notice
okay maybe it's because i made that
comment about his hair sticking out
so like i never comment about your hair
yes you
do all the time oh wait
come on what's the question hold on what
did you ask me yesterday hey guys love
the show
so we had two questions yesterday for
ask lunch money if you have a question
for us
do hashtag ask lm in the
comments below which this person did not
do but this person did not do but i like
their question
but first i'm going to go with nasami
his question is he is the proper hashtag
his question is what do you think would
be the three biggest sectors to invest
in during this decade
you go first then i will go now you go i
think that
um i think that skin care
for both men and women i think fertility
startups
are going to be huge they already are
kind of exploding
um and the third one i think is
tracking of all sorts of health uh
things so quantified self there you go
those are mine what are yours
i'm gonna pick different ones just so
that there's a variety of information
remember did you not agree with mine i
think all of those are good uh
i would go with bitcoin psychedelics
and uh i'll just call
um all of the things around
uh remote work so what i mean by that is
like not so much but yeah there's plenty
of software companies
but also things like there's going to be
a company that is built
that simply builds like mini offices
in your backyard so you can like walk
out of your house and go into your
kind of separate area your office uh but
it's on your property
um or there might be some places where
everyone's a remote worker but you all
come together
uh so you have some kind of like uh
community um there's likely to be
somebody who figures out like hey
houses now should be built with much
more robust
uh home offices um what does it look
like even after a code if it's over
yeah for sure because what people are
realizing is like maybe you're not going
to work from home 100 of the time but
you're also not going to go into the
office 100 of the time
it's just going to become much more
acceptable for you to work from home
yeah uh for a period of time so maybe
it's three days at home two days in the
office or
you know the flip-flop or whatever but i
think that's a big one
psychedelics uh absolutely there
is a massive increase in um
depression uh suicidal thoughts mental
health issues all that kind of stuff
coming out of this
uh and we also are starting to see like
the state of oregon
just came out with a new law that is
going to legalize
um some uh some ingredients in the
psychedelic space that'll be interesting
and there's a lot of other companies
compass pathways is public uh field trip
health you know
a couple of these guys future health is
public uh i
believe that i don't they're not on
nasdaq or anything but there are more of
the smaller
uh exchanges i think and then uh bitcoin
obviously
um i think that bitcoin is going to uh
disrupt
gold at a minimum if not uh you know
nation state currencies and so that's
going to be pretty uh
pretty incredible to watch hey oh okay
there's a pandemic so the other question
i thought was really good taylor asks
hey guys love the show
ah you're the best taylor my question is
what would you recommend a person do
right now if they're looking to take the
first step or steps towards leaving
their boring nine-to-five job and
becoming a self-sufficient individual
can i answer first sure okay so
the first step i would like my biggest
regret in not starting the profile when
i did is that i didn't start it earlier
so don't quit your job but start
doing whatever it is you want to do kind
of on the side on weekends on evening
evenings
and it because you love doing it it'll
kind of give you you'll be excited to do
it on weekends
and i know that a lot of people say oh
what's your path to profitability what's
your business model look like
the beauty of a lot of these things is
like if it's truly original and if
you're doing this
sometimes the business model is not
obvious in the beginning
it wasn't for me i did not start a
newsletter with the idea that it would
become a business
i was talking to humans of new york
creator brandon stanton recently
his the model of whatever he created did
not exist when he started photographing
people
on the street so i think like it might
take a while to figure out
how to make money off of it but just
start doing something you love now
i agree with all of that the only two
things i would add are
uh one you should set a goal uh
in terms of uh when you're gonna leave
by
and also set a goal for uh an amount of
money that you need to be making
in order to make that jump so what
happens is a lot of people just say oh
like i want to leave but they never set
goals there's no forcing function
um but if you got a nine-to-five job
that you want to quit you know let's say
that you said okay
i want to uh replace my salary
that was my goal you know use the easy
number let's say that you get paid
you know sixty thousand dollars a year
right so 5k a month
and uh i want to replace that then you
work backwards you say all right
i'm gonna leave in six months from now
can i figure out how to make five
thousand dollars a month doing whatever
the other thing i want to do is
uh in the next six months and basically
you know
set both a amount goal and also a timing
goal
uh so that you have something that
you're kind of working towards and then
track it
right so understand okay in the first
month how much money did i make i made
three hundred dollars okay well that's
directionally towards five thousand but
i got a ways to go you know in month
three okay now i'm making twenty five
hundred bucks wow
i'm making progress here you know by
month six oh i'm only making
four thousand dollars not five thousand
uh should i leave
right or do i need to wait another month
like now you can kind of
measure um you know what your confidence
level is
uh and then at the same time like you
got to be comfortable i think
uh kind of taking some risk which
basically means
you got to bet on yourself but you
better be damn sure that
whatever you're going to do has the
potential to grow into what you want it
to be
because there's a lot of people frankly
who don't have jobs right now and so if
you
um quit and you know six months from now
you need a job
yeah if you're talented sure there's
always gonna be jobs available but if
you're also now competing with a hundred
other people
um you know you just gotta make sure
that you're making the right decision
another thing
i'll say is um i started thinking about
leaving my job back in january
so i kept i call it the seesaw of misery
like i would wake up and be like i'm
ready to do it and i'd go to sleep and
be like are you
crazy so he was on the receiving end of
this seesaw so i kept
being like all about it and then not
sure and then
going back and forth so he said this was
back in january when anthony was like
i'm i'm
done listening to this i will not talk
to you
until you literally circle a date in
your calendar
when you think will be your last day at
your job
and in january i went and circled a date
and i
literally completely forgot that i did
this but you you'll find when you make a
decision your mind kind of stops
freaking out and you start moving
towards that decision
um when i was leaving my job
i was looking in my planner that i used
religiously
and i saw that march 20th was circled
and i was like what the hell was this
and then i remembered it was when i
circled that i would leave and that
actually ended up being my last day
which is
mind-blowing that i showed him and
freaked out and all that stuff but
it's just like once you make a decision
you naturally tend to move in that
direction i never freak out
okay he doesn't you do every once in a
while it's okay
yeah but do you remember when i showed
you the thing set a date
stick to it stop being soft
oh okay you want to work for yourself go
work for yourself you want to work for
somebody else go work for somebody else
it's all up to you personal
responsibility embrace it that's it for
lunch monday today guys thank you guys
thank you
for watching see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends